talk about moving the goal posts
as it happens melissa zeligman and
victor angel are also
on their way to a soccer pitch these
amateur players meet up for soccer
practice in brooklyn
every week the view of manhattan is an
added bonus
melissa hopes to interest the players in
a somewhat unusual football nice to meet
you
so this is the socket yeah it is a
soccer ball that stores the kinetic
energy from play
so as the ball plays it stores the
energy in an internal mechanism
and then you can use it to power a light
so like 30 minutes of play with the ball
will power a light for three hours let's
try this out
and first pencil kit
right now the ball costs 100
that's a little pricey but otherwise it
gets the thumbs up
it seems a little light so maybe just
like
um it's like regular soccer ball bounces
more
it's interesting it's got a neat texture
to it uh the balance you have to adjust
to it
um i'm just wondering what's inside of
it because it feels really cool
i like juggling it it was easy to juggle
because it's pretty light
so i haven't tried kicking it too far
but in terms of just juggling and
keeping it close it's pretty good
the socket was designed by victor who is
a keen soccer player himself
it's a lithium-ion battery similar to
the one you can find in iphones or other
electronic devices it's rechargeable and
it's geared towards children in
developing countries that don't have
access to power
so they're able to play for a few
minutes every day go back home
plug in an led lamp and be able to do
their homework or other
tasks around the house so far
development of the socket has been
funded by donations but
victor angel and melissa zeligman hope
that at some point it will become
financially viable
the 25 year old technician is planning
to keep refining the design
the aim is to introduce it in places
where there's no access to electricity
uh one of the biggest things was making
it light enough for
children to play right now it's about 50
grams heavier than a traditional soccer
ball
it's completely airless so it doesn't
puncture a lot of times when you donate
balls to the developing world they go
flat in a matter of weeks and end up in
the landfill
this one you can actually play around in
the rain or in the mud
the main question is obviously does it
really work
a football that can power a lamp a very
illuminating idea